it seems to help us to answer some of
the open big fundamental questions in
physics and so it stays on the table
[Music]
I'm going to move to our first theme but
I'm going to come back to you since
you've teeded up so nicely and that's
what makes a scientific theory
successful so so I we take the point
about no experimental proof but but
success is one of those things that we
might still have in the offing and I
wonder whether you would settle for
plausibility coherence congruence with
other things we think of the sort that
you've just laid out or if you think
even beyond that as something that we
might be aiming for that would say
that's a really successful Theory
well again successful now is a word we'd
have to talk about
um for pragmatic purposes Newtonian
mechanics was very successful Maxwell
and electrodynamics was very successful
they turned out to be wrong okay so
there's a certain kind of technological
success and even predictive success we
know you can get out of theories that
are on the wrong foundations
um to be what I said was to be plausible
right what makes it reasonable to take a
theory seriously maybe to say it's the
best thing we have on offer now or maybe
it's not developed yet but it's
worthwhile putting some time into it uh
and there I think I don't think there's
just a menu there are a bunch of
different general characteristics and
then they have to be deployed
specifically to the case because often
you have a list of competitors and
you're making a relative judgment
between them what gets a little scary is
when the physicists don't have a list
and this was one of the things that
happened with string Theory and it's hey
day was they said oh the best argument
for the theory it's the only game in
town right there are no competitors and
that was just a bad idea there better be
competitors or you should be really
looking for them right and not not
squashing down people who are looking in
other directions so I want to ask Marika
a similar question about the idea of a
successful Theory because
suppose we do have competitors suppose
as well as um you know the theory
there's a there's a foil at least
something else that's there by which we
can we can judge it you you hinted and I
want to see if if you were standing by
this you hinted it when you're doing
purely theoretic radical physics you
might be looking at elegance and beauty
of the theory and and I want to sort of
read something that the late Peter
Lipton asked should we be looking for
the likeliest or the loveliest Theory
and it's the loveliest a strong enough
Criterion to make it a successful theory
yes so I think it's I think it's an
interesting point because it's one which
is discussed quite a lot in in physics
at the moment of
you know so so what is it
um I mean almost alluded to in the
discussion was you know people believe
in in people have a strong confidence
that a theory is on the right lines even
without experimental evidence so for me
in a sense the most recent example
of a theory which was really a big jump
which had no experimental evidence was
Einstein's theory of general relativity
right because you know the the tests I
mean the tests and of solar system
physics were really not what made people
believe it they believed it I think from
the time it came out and they believed
it because of the Elegance of the way
that it kind of you know you know
unifies
um special relativity it brought in
electromagnetism it kind of reduced to
Newtonian Syria in the in all the limits
where the Newtonian Theory had been
tested But ultimately more than anything
I think it was the mathematical Elegance
the way it came out
but now as we move a century later you
can say well
should a theory be should a fundamental
Theory necessarily have Elegance
symmetry just because it's nice so the
obvious the obvious example over the
last 40 to 50 years has been that we
seem to see in nature two distinct
categories of particles some of them
have you know integers bins and some of
them have half integer spins and there
are theories that sort of say that these
sit on there's some kind of symmetry
which links these things these things
seem to be a priori quite distinct from
each other but there seems to be
something you know you could group them
in a theory where they're actually kind
of linked to each other but we've seen
no hints of this in experiments so
should we trust this
and if you just relied on experimental
evidence I'd say throw it out of the
water now the reason I I would keep it
on the table is it does seem to do some
very conceptually elegant things for us
in that it does help us you know
reconcile the paradoxes of combining
quantum mechanics and gravity you have
to do a little bit more than use this
symmetry you have to do some other
things as well but it seems to help us
to answer some of the open big
fundamental questions in physics and so
it stays on the table but do we exclude
other things that you know do the same
no we don't we should leave everything
on the table and that's where I say you
you've got this you know you you've got
this way to use your resources right you
you have to try and make judgments about
what looks the most promising
as the strings here so I have to say I
have never said this is the only game in
town and no you shouldn't uh you
shouldn't pursue it's as you say it's
completely opposite right you want to
pursue everything that's promising but
you almost have an unspoken mental list
of why you think things are more
promising than others I'd like to see
actually more theorists articulate and
actually they shouldn't say well
Princeton and Harvard are following this
it shouldn't be sociologically driven it
shouldn't be that the big people in the
field are doing it they should be
articulating for themselves why is this
the most promising Avenue to explore
that's really tantalizing and I think in
in a lot of you know very hard
intellectual work across a number of
different domains we have that feeling
that you you know you've got some ideas
of what makes this the likeliest thing
and you're being very ecumenical keep
all of those hypotheses open but you
still have a feeling there's there's a
reason to to to believe some things more
likely and and could I invite you to
start your project and to say what
you're lying on you said there should be
more discussion of this you know what
what is it that's giving you that beyond
beyond instinct or gut feeling or
perhaps your training leading you to
favor certain things could you be sure
that there's something more
um reliable that you're you're using
so so okay this gives me a beautiful
opportunity to segue into my own field
of research which everyone loves to talk
about so I work on whether quantum
theories of gravity can be in fact
understood in terms of theories without
gravity in one less Dimension okay so
that's that's a kind of a wacky way out
idea in some perspective right you know
that the world around us three
macroscopic dimensions is some somehow
just created from a flatline world that
has no gravity at all so you're asking
why would I work on this why do I find
it promising is because actually we have
shown that this works in so many you
know sense toy examples not examples
that we can go and observe things in the
universe but we have actually done
calculations in quantum theories and
shown that they actually reproduce
gravitational calculations so there's a
lot of theoretical evidence that's
theoretical computational evidence that
this is promising and it's promising
because it could reconcile many of the
big questions of of quantum quantum
gravity you know the face of black holes
the resolution of the singularity at the
beginning of the universe so it's
actually a weight of theoretical
evidence I would say that I'm evaluating
but actually kind of articulating in you
know why do you put more weight on some
theoretical papers than others that
becomes quite technical right because
it's actually about a list of I want it
to behave this way when I do my
calculations I want the calculations to
be well defined and not be beset by
Infinities and this particular Theory
solves those problems and these other
attempts do not do so that's that's
really helpful and I'm going to come to
Harry now as the our our
village experimentalist to tell us the
or that the main Criterion for Success
here is is um you know is it is it is it
going to be testable are you going to
find something that tests it and I'm
just wondering whether
in for all the Elegance whether you
think we shouldn't expect A Simple
Theory of a complex world and sometimes
the experiments are going to depart from
some of these very tantalizing elegant
hypotheses I think yeah there's a couple
of points I wanted to pick up on I mean
I suppose first of all I mean from an
experiment my point of view I think we
there's a tendency sometimes to equate
theories with a true description of
reality but I think really theories are
a models they're approximations of
reality so you know even in a theory as
beautiful as Einstein's generally theory
of relativity it's it's still an
approximate model of reality and we know
at some at some point it must break down
and that's indeed why people work on
string theory but it's also I think
there's a sort of there's a slight I
think there's a slightly miselling of
the history of general relativity in the
sense that it's true that it's very I
mean you know even as an experimentalist
I can appreciate its elegance and its
beauty but actually Einstein himself
when he was working on it in 1915 before
he made his big announcement that he'd
come up with his theory the first thing
he did was he calculated using his
theory the orbit of mercury and there'd
be a long-standing problem that mercury
was moving slightly too quickly around
the sun when astronomers kept trying to
catch it transiting the Sun and they
realized it'd already gone past and this
has been a big problem through the whole
19th century people invented all kinds
of solutions like in a planet called
Vulcan which was between Mercury and the
Sun and eventually there's this planet
wasn't discovered and so you know people
didn't really know what was going on and
Einstein suspected that his theory was
the solution to this and he actually
wrote him in his diary that he
calculated the orbit of mercury using
generativity and when he got exactly the
correct answer he gave him heart
palpitations so for him that was the
moment when he realized that you know
this theory was a true well true it
shouldn't use that word but an accurate
description of the world and then you
know in terms of persuading the rest of
the community it was actually a an
eclipse Expedition organized by Arthur
Eddington in 1919 where they sent two
ships out to the South Atlantic one in
Brazil won an island to see whether the
light from Stars around the Sun during
an eclipse was bent according to
Einstein's prediction and that was the
point again where you know in in the
sort of broader scientific Community the
ethereum became accepted it really was
only with the actual experimental
evidence and you know the Triumph of
Einstein's theory since then has been
all these predictions that have been
made gravitational waves most recently
that have then been improved to be the
case so I think you know had none of
those bits of evidence been there I very
much doubt that general relativity would
have really gained any traction despite
its internal you know Beauty and
consistency and so on so I think you
know ultimately you do have to make
contact react with reality I mean I
accept the problem that you have in
string theory where you're you're
dealing with energy scales that are so
far beyond any conceivable experiment
that we might you know be able to do you
talk about 50 or 100 years but I'd say
in a thousand years maybe you know you
would to get to the energy scales to you
know to sort of where you see these
effects of quantum gravity with current
LHC type technology you need a machine
the size of the Milky Way and that's not
gonna not gonna get funded anytime soon
so you do I suppose have to then proceed
on different sorts of arguments as
marika's laid out but I think we have to
sort of you know remember that
ultimately all of these theories are
trying to describe nature as we observe
it and there is a bit of a question in
my mind if you know if the the sort of
things that you're ultimately trying to
describe are unobservable you know
can you how how interesting is this is
ultimately I suppose to continue
watching this video click the link in
the top left or in the description below
or visit iai.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas